leute wirklich man so unfassbar bock auf
urlaub ihr könnt euch das vorstellen ich
wäre so gerne jetzt im urlaub ich meinen
wir haben mitte september in deutschland
das wetter ist schon wieder seit einer
woche scheiße gerade regnet es geregnet
ich hatte vor einigen tagen geburtstag
heute abend noch eine kleine garten
party machen wir haben 16 grad naja was
willst du machen ich hatte gestern aber
mal so die vision was wäre wenn du
einfach genau jetzt losfährt und auf die
malediven fliegt das ist nicht immer so
mein traumziel ich wollte immer mal hin
das sieht immer so cool aus und dann kam
mir die idee daraus doch ein kleines
video projekt zu machen weil ich muss
aktuell arbeiten aber so meine ganzen
freunde ein bisschen neidisch zu machen
vielleicht auch euch als zuschauer
dachte ich mir denken wir doch einfach
mal eine fette malediven reisen
das hört sich erst mal ein bisschen
zögern ich muss auch sagen ich bin ich
der erste der so viel kreisen aber wir
werden das ein bisschen anders machen
und ich werde mir mühe geben und mal
schauen wie die reaktion von meinen
freunden sind von meiner familie ich
werde das niemanden sagen von euch als
zuschauern und ja wir müssen uns jetzt
ein bisschen wir einen 15 wochen war
schon um 22 uhr heute geht mein flieger
wir fliegen über dubai direkt nach
malediven und wie ich das ganze an
stelle und so weiter und so fort erfahrt
ihr alles im video ich wünsche euch ganz
ganz viel spaß beim zuschauen und ich
hab letzte leute ohne chance das wetter
ist einfach eiskalt man habe ich gerade
schon mal dran ist werden jetzt ein
partner der ländlich malediven und da
habe ich verschiedene clips eingeladen
aktuell sind das erst sieben aber da
werden noch jede menge zu kommen die
habe ich halt einfach auflegen welchem
red and stories geklaut ich weiß gar
nicht was darf aber habe ich es gemacht
die brauche ich halt so als lückenfüller
und den restlichen content politik
komplett selber wir werden auch fotos
machen wir werden die fällt ihm ein paar
mit ziemlich auch sein jetzt erstmal
noch kurz zum friseur zu gehen und mir
eine schöne sunny frisur zu verpassen
damit gleich geile fotos man kann von
einer weißen wand und da muss ich mir
extrem viel mühe gegeben dass staaten
jetzt erst mal ich nehme euch ein
bisschen mit zeige euch wichtig fotos
machen und heute abend geht es dann los
auf meine einwöchige malediven reise ich
habe bock endlich wieder in die sonne
meine eltern und meinen bruder wissen
davon nichts das kann lustig werden weil
meine eltern haben zwar kein insta mein
bruder und er wird in das selbst sagen
und dann das wird geil altbestand in
meiner freundin erzählte ich auch nichts
davon negative durchgehend als wirklich
leute was geht kurz unterbrechung ich
habe es gerade tatsächlich in den urlaub
geschafft natürlich nicht auf die
malediven ich versuche nur einen kumpel
im süden von deutschland ich wollte euch
nur kurz darauf hinweisen dass ich
dieses jahr teilnehmer war mit meinem
team dem team wie bei der nbbl 2021 der
nerd blaster league auf dem nbbl kanal
ist jetzt auch das erste video online
das ganze ist so gesehen ein nerv
turnier gegen andere teams andere
youtuber influenza sind auch dabei mein
team war das team die zusammen mit josh
homme und loris wir waren auf jeden fall
das feuerwehr team und haben da
ordentlich gut rasiert glaube ich hier
folgen jetzt ein paar ausschnitte erster
link in der beschreibung kommt ihr auf
den nbbl kanal und noch ganz ganz
wichtig ich verlose ich noch zwei nerd
blaster mega coole dinge müsste ich
einfach nur ein kommentar schreiben was
sie damit machen wollt und checkt auf
jeden fall den nerv den nbbl kanal aus
[Musik]
32 so und die 60 sekunden ansage werden
gemacht damit zur nächsten station
gegangen wird und die sind richtig
kaputt 12 welcher für team wie heute
noch so party in seinem ersten match der
erste der hier über den roters leiter
und die zeit ist letztendlich und 60
sekunden
und team wie hat die jetzt 60 sekunden
zeigten sich erst mal zeit und gar nicht
von den anderen beeinflussen der los hat
unter ladehemmung
14 16 18
auch
18.18 becher was wir gerade schon
erwähnte erstes unentschieden da wird
man sich wahrscheinlich in zehn jahren
noch daran erinnern hoffe ich team wie
gegen die erste mal dein team des st
damit verabschiede ich mich und wünsche
euch viel spaß beim weiteren video
neue friese und so haare bisschen kürzer
auf oder aus frisur angelehnt ich
befinde mich auf jeden fall jetzt in
einer woche da haben wir schon ein
kleines center aufgebaut einmal hier
schön die sonnen beleuchtung und meine
kamera mit der ich jetzt da ich fotos
mache in guter qualität ich habe mir
hier ein paar sommer outfit ausgesucht
das ist das erste jahr hier schön mit
dieser meisten bade buchse dann habe ich
doch ein anderes am start und auch eine
andere badehose und dann machen jetzt
drei weiße pick
ups und bietet ein bisschen auf meine
lieben ich freue mich so
dann könnt ihr mit schaum haben wir
erstmals so richtig so oft lässt sich
doch alles
okay damit kann man auf jeden fall schon
arbeiten bayer geht so meine lieben
brille gefunden check check weiter
geht's könnte die kamera noch ein
bisschen weiter nach oben positionieren
so sagen ja ist ja doch endlich ich will
mich
auf meine lieben
meinung nach hier daher unklar ist aber
nicht so war das reine schon auto
wechseln jetzt habe ich eine neue bade
buchse an natürlich auch einer kammer
frei ist ganz wichtig
1 noch hierher in die
sich das eigentlich schon vor ein auto
immer noch
der klassische juli sollte die fotos
sind ab geschuldet wir schauen uns die
ergebnisse dann heute abend an und am
morgen nach dem für mich geht es
allerdings gleich dem gelenk schon los
und die bilder war ich danach nach
boston und ich freue mich schon auf
direkte und vor allem von meinen
freunden und familie
sind doch irgendwie witzig ich habe die
fotos dann bei mir im wohnzimmer gemacht
und habe die selber bearbeitet dann habe
ich noch ein foto von damals aus dem
urlaub genommen und das auch noch ein
bisschen bearbeitet als damit einfach
leichter ging und auch viel
realistischer aus sondern sich um dieses
foto das hab ich dann später auch bei
entstammen gepostet
okay leute dann startet man abonnieren
von jetzt den kopf über sorgte auch am
stammplatz an sich sowie auch zum
flughafen die werde ich erst sozusagen
morgenpost wenn ich dann schon vor bin
und ich weiß es niemand damit rechnen
wie ich bin gespannt aktion
vor allem
was mir dass jeder glauben will also
zählt ausgeht
dass ich habe meine spontane reise
gebucht es war
das erste mal wir haben ja deshalb neu
für mich sagte jobs am flughafen
ich habe mega spontan bereit gewesen
urlaub 14 stündigen frau menton fiel mir
nicht halt durch fest auf die partymeile
tiefen und ich bin einfach alleine so
ich denke das sollten wir machen jetzt
erst den flughafen die würde ich mir das
ding ist ich werde dieses sowie das post
und ich da bin damit ich nicht unnötig
gegen diese reaktion direkt bekommen
hier auf die vielfältige sport ist okay
leute gebraucht und es ist mir ganz gut
gelungen das zu laufen dann den islam
gilt auch und das forstamt als morgen
meine story ist bis jetzt nur so lang
dass man nicht mehr sehen kann wo ich
ankomme also die malediven 12 sind noch
gar nicht drin ist damit schon so viele
leute geschrieben und das hat mir
wirklich niemand hat mir gesagt du bist
nicht in dubai also alles so erfasst was
geht da also für mich dass meine freunde
und so und jetzt schauen wir mal was
doch ins hören so abgehen wobei gut an
sich es sieht auch halt einfach mal aus
die nächste was auf einmal ein anderer
bild schmalz ob das nicht auffällt luca
checkt dann hat mir noch meinen bruder
geschrieben bist du jetzt echt auf den
malediven oder ist das feld ich sie ja
eher so also völlig zurecht sag das mal
machen als ob ich mal bildet euch video
geschickt danach als kleine stütze
geschrieben machen mit stimme dann glaub
ich dann habe ich standort geschickt
aber ich habe ein geschossen weil ich
habe am start geschickt jetzt 42 minuten
von hier ist in dubai nagel heißt und
ich glaube immer das gepäck maria ich
damit auch zeit freilegen können aber
die ist leider das heißt leider die
wollte eigentlich schon vorgestern
fahren aber sie ist immer noch hier
deswegen ging es nicht ich habe jetzt
auf jeden fall schon mal einiges meine
story gepostet das gute war ein kumpel
von mir der jonas des war viel in der
welt unterwegs zum beispiel auch oft in
dubai hat ein paar sequenzen drüber
geschichte habe ich meine story gepackt
so sieht das aus ihres staates video wo
ich noch im aufzug war und dann ging es
schon direkt in die luft nach dubai next
stop dann haben wir hier ein schönes
video aus der business class glock
vor dem fernseher hier jetzt auch wieder
gleich geht die sonne auf habe ich dazu
geschrieben denn dubai und ich wollte
mir noch ein bisschen die stadt
anschauen und dann hier paar sequenzen
so andere welt hier ich bin mal gespannt
wie die direktion zur ausnahme werden
wir wollen wir glauben oder nicht wir
werden sehen so leute was geht jetzt ist
es so weit ich habe gerade noch die
malediven clips eingeladen hier da kann
man schon sehen ich
bin schon auf den malediven gelandet und
jetzt werde ich ja auch ich denke es ist
so langsam an der zeit ein foto zu
posten bei diesem hier würde ich sagen
jetzt klar deswegen passt mir das jetzt
mal und checken die reaktion am bach so
und ich habe nochmal ein filter darüber
gelegt damit es noch echter aussieht
verarbeiten wir das ein bisschen
ab
jetzt schreibe ich dazu endlich
angekommen das leben hier fühlt sich an
wie im traum wofür dass ich hier in
deutschland sitze mit einer erkältung es
regnet und das ist alles andere als ein
trauben gerade naja fake social media
was willst du dazu sagen es gibt
bestimmt leute die wirklich so krank
sachen verhältnis jetzt geben wir noch
ein hirn ahlem alle tiefs very good und
dann würde ich sagen posten war das
ganze mal let's go okay leute post
online ich bin gespannt auf die
reaktionen die wir später bekommen ich
werde es dann heute abend euch mal
zeigen noch keinen kommentar das später
okay wäre jetzt mittlerweile viertel vor
acht das foto ist jetzt echt einige zeit
online und wir haben noch einige
reaktionen bekommen ich bin mega
gespannt ich werde euch das hier immer
einblenden erstmal geht es hier war
jetzt glaube ich noch um die stories
weil so langsam kann ich das ganze dann
natürlich auch mal auflösen udo hat
geschrieben der song bruder da muss ich
aber ganz schnell los scheiße die
stories jetzt raus welcher song waren
dass felix schreibt was für eine
kooperation wird das hh haben wir gute
rezension bekommt zu meinem frühstück
von heute morgen geil geil geil dann
haben wir hier noch einen die reaktion
auf sagt nicht bescheid schick postkarte
oder auch gute reise also man muss
wirklich festhalten von den leuten die
jetzt nur die stories gesehen haben hat
jeder geglaubt dann kam allerdings eben
ein features und daraufhin habe ich
wirklich viele reaktionen bekommen das
ist absolut fake ist eine freundin aus
meiner uni ihn damals hat mir
geschrieben dass sie bei einem bild die
kommentare gelesen hat und sich so
dachte wird er fast geht mit den leuten
die haben alle fake geschrieben und
daraufhin hab ich hier so ein video
geschickt aus deutschland und sie ist
auch ich fand's lustig weil sie jetzt
halt 0 gezeigt das ist wild fake war das
war aber glaube ich auch eine der großen
ausnahmen kaufhof schreibt dein
hintergrund sie zu unrecht aus ich denke
das ist nicht echt lukas kommentiert da
bin ich dabei juliane fähig lärm das ist
ein fake und qualität vom toaster also
so schlimm ist es auch nicht gewesen
oder also ich fand das bild echt gut
dass es auch nur einen traum niemals
fliegst du ohne marie dahin wobei
endlich mache ich urlaub oder okay ich
war das ist ein bisschen nach hinten los
gegangen ich habe mir gedacht dass die
leute ist zum großen teil glauben werden
weil eigentlich jede influence drin
bearbeitet ja ihre urlaubsbilder
geistesgestört ich fand mainz da
eigentlich noch wenig bearbeitet aus im
gegensatz zu meiner instagram explore
page aber gut bei den stories hatte ich
echt viele lustige reaktionen die mich
zum lachen gebracht deswegen auch für
mich das experiment ein voller erfolg
beim foto naja ist es dann vielleicht
leicht aufgeflogen ich hoffe es hat euch
spaß macht beim anschauen ich habe mir
echt mühe gegeben leider hat es nicht
ganz so krass geklappt wie ich es mir
erhofft habe heute das was von mir und
kanal abonnieren auch ganz wichtig